former New Jersey Governor Chris
Christie is revealing his 15-year
friendship with Donald Trump in his new
memoir it's called let me finish Trump
the Kushner's Bannen New Jersey and the
power of in-your-face politics Christie
writes that he went from the vice
presidential shortlist to being fired
from the transition team two days after
the election he says the president's
son-in-law Jared Kushner pushed him out
setting the stage for problems inside
the Trump administration in Christie's
words the president is surrounded by
quote a revolving door of deeply flawed
individuals amateurs
grifters convicted and unconvicted
felons Governor Christie good morning
morning John that's quite a list let me
ask you about one of those members Roger
stone you were a former US Attorney yeah
Roger stones complaining about the way
he's been treated that pre-dawn raid is
that out of the ordinary yes it is and
and I will tell you that one of the
things when I was when I was watching
the reports that my wife asked me would
you have done that and I said the only
way I would have ever done that is US
attorney is if we knew that he had a gun
and and if so someone has a gun and
you're in dining them you worry about
them killing themselves or harming
others when I found out that Rogers
don't did not have a gun I think it was
over the top for them to do that because
otherwise he's not a flight risk
how could Roger stone get out of the car
CBS's Jeff Pegues reports that Roger
stone has told him that in fact the FBI
came in and seized electronic devices
multiple cell phones that he had could
that have been the purpose of this race
you can do that but you don't need to
bring you know guys with ar-15s and in
in flak jackets as if they're gonna get
shot when I saw them coming in with all
the protective gear its signaled to me
well they must know there are weapons
inside which in Florida the given the
gun what do you think was that
I think they were trying to intimidate
them and I think it's the wrong thing
for prosecutors to do I think that mr.
Muller made a mistake in authorizing
that because you're going to be
criticizing rightfully so if you're a
prosecutor using those means as a means
of intimidation if you're using it as a
way to protect FBI agents that's
completely appropriate and I've done it
official it's interesting to hear you
side against Robert Muller and for
someone like Roger stone as I've
supported Muller all along but when
you're wrong you're wrong he said that's
treated fairly and professionally though
well yeah it's yeah they did act that
way I didn't expect the FBI to act
differently but when you get a pound on
your door at 6:00 a.m. in the dark and
you see a bunch of FBI agents with flack
jackets on and and semi-automatic
weapons I mean to take somebody out who
lied to Congress that's just to me
that's overkill it and I and and and I
talked about this during the time and I
was US Attorney in the book these are
tough decisions to make but you always
have to err on the side of having people
have confidence in the justice system I
have confidence in mr. Muller and in his
objectivity I worked with him when I was
US Attorney and he was directly the FBI
so I've defended Bob all throughout this
investigation I don't believe it's a
witch-hunt but when you do stuff like
that those are unforced errors that make
everybody take a step back and say come
on let's talk about your book you paint
a picture here of the Trump
administration that is a complete and
thorough mess this is the presidency of
the United States he's got people
working for him we're going after me
he's got members of his family who are
undermining they undermine you you done
all this work on the transition which is
a major operation for trillion-dollar
government they throw it all in the
trash can
President Trump came into office saying
I have a special ability because of my
business experience to run places in
shipshape what you describe here is a
total jalopy mess well listen what I try
to do in the book is to let people know
the truth unlike some of these other
books that that gossip and and give
these backroom kind of like you know
titillating stories I was in all these
rooms in and helping to prepare this guy
for the presidency and to prepare the
transition and I think the untold story
that has not been spoken enough about is
that that transition got thrown out 140
people not me 140 people worked on that
transition from May till November and
Steve Bannon and Jared Kushner and Rick
Dearborn made the decision for the
president to throw that out and they
told them we'll handle it and that
turned out to be mistake and I think
even the president today acknowledges
that that was you also talk about the
Russia investigation and you go hard
after Jeff Sessions saying that he
should not have recused himself why most
legal experts say he would have
where that he should have told the
president that how would he have known
though that the investigation what if in
fact if well first of all we all knew
was ongoing at that time everybody knew
that there was an investigation going on
at that time not after he met with the
Russians though no no I'm talking about
when the president came to him to say I
want you to be Attorney General he knew
at that point he had been involved in
the campaign if the reason he was
recusing was because he was involved in
the campaign he didn't know that didn't
know that and Maru knew it Marx but
didn't know it in November he knew it
and and the prom be on is that you the
president had a right to know that and
to me he may have picked sessions anyway
but he had a right to know that sessions
was going to recuse himself so that he
could evaluate that along with the other
candidates and decide
despite that is Jeff still the best
person the person I want maybe the
president wouldn't decide to do that I
doubt he would have and I think he
deprived the president of information he
did this is what I'm talking about
throughout the book John is that you
know the president's been ill served by
people who were not ready for prime time
and and that's happened again and again
and again and these jobs are tough
enough when you have a good staff
Governor Christie you paint a picture of
repeated mistakes over and over again
even when you counseled him differently
thank you so much for joining us this
morning or FX for having me on see you
always good to see you too let me finish
goes on sale tomorrow